Today we are going to play a match with Russian Matryoshka dolls
After each point you win
You place the doll on the table
And if you hit the doll
you lose the point and go one step back
First one to get to the smallest one wins
Ok, let's make the draw
I'll take this side
You get the red Matryoshka
But I'm confident with this little one!
How can you lose with that?
Team bandana!
Come on!
I'm placing it on the backhand side
No! She has lost the bandana!
There is no way we are going to win this point!
It's okay
Still defending the backhand side
Almost hit the blue one
Come on Babushka!
We can do this!
That's some impressive playing, guys!
Otto is just playing better when the Babushkas get smaller!
That's true!
Next is this
What!?
No! Emil why are you laughing?
I had it under control!
Time to open up
Mama Matryoshka
In the middle
And we'll put the bandana... it's her secret weapon!
She got it on!
I have to go one step back now
I get to progress
We should have like mini bandanas that I put on...
Yes! Good footwork
Back you go
Ok, you are back!
A bit smaller than the first one!
Oh you got through my defense
Second defense over here
Newest member of the team
I think it was the wind!
Ok, let's check what the VAR (video assistant referee) says!
That's a clear hit!
One step back
You might be seeing a pattern here
There is 5 more in here
Yea, imagine: 5 more!
And we are supposed to play with them!
You may be taller but... I'm faster!
How did that go on?
My newest recruit
This is the Matryoshak
And this is the ball
They are all looking at me
They are still quite scary looking like!
Where did it go?
Maybe it's just distracting me more if I put it there but...
Let's go with that
He is knocking down his own team!
I said it's going to distract me!
You were right
It's like a half of a ping pong ball
Nice one
There we have it!
I'm sorry
Just for fun, I leave this here
And this point, this makes no sense
Around the net!
I had to go for it!
Always have to go for around the nets
In any situation, you always have to go for it!
You mean there is still 1 more?
Yea, there is 1 more!
I wonder what's the right technique with this?
Not a single shot was hit with the doll
Wow this is so small
You can go there
Final generation!
Good shot baby Matryoshka!
Well done!
And guys
We heard that there is still a lot of you who haven't subscribed
Don't do that!
Remember to subscribe
Oh I lost a part of me!
So help Pongfinity
And subscribe to their channel
Until next time!